red sox are five and one when chris
sales starts and chris sill ready to get
after it mo 297 with six home runs
and in there strike three still gotta
look for that number how many times he's
made a start and it started just like
that yeah fastball down and in 95. and
here comes the polar bear pete alonso
261 34 home runs 2-2
put him away
back with the heat at 96.
two down and here's lindor
chopper down to third fair ball behind
the bag long throw by divers in a good
one he's almost on the edge of the
outfield grass along the line taiwan
walker you know in the first half of the
season i was trying to figure out he
really had a plan in each and every game
what he wanted to do he's kind of lost
himself so whenever that happens for a
starting pitcher you go back
keep it simple be aggressive
and there's strike three called about
looking at a fastball one out base is
empty for kyle schwarber
261-29 home runs looking to get to
number 30. swinging a high fly ball
center field emmo's back and turning
this one is gone
there's number 30 for schwarber oh my
goodness and this is no cheapy this is
bridgefolk get the tape
this is over 440 feet i mean this ball
is kissed cross scene cheese right down
broadway and he lift take off see ya
the red sox have him on the corners here
with one down
well there's a base hit he's picked up
an rbi
again to score xander bogarts raphael
heading into third
95 and counting for jd two to nothing
drops down to first jd davis
yes yeah he went on the slider and two
down mcneal will bat and jeff pokes one
the other way down the line that's a
fair ball going into the corner baez
will score mcneal heads to second he's
in standing with an rbi double he cut in
half and brings up pilar
got him to go he committed and he struck
him out so he picks up two more k's in
the inning but a run does score
first and third top of the order and kik
hernandez who struck out looking in the
first inning
swing hit hard and fair down the third
base line past the backhanded dive of
jonathan vr
renfro has scored iglesias will be held
at third it's a double for [ __ ] and an
rbi the second and third with only one
out brings up schwarber
here's another one tidy drive right
field pilar back to the bullpen
how do you pitch to him is beyond me
he got him again
five or ten with five jacks
over the bullpen three run johnson
nicely done
31 for kyle schwarber
two at bats two home runs four rbis for
kyle schwarber
says we can on at second and nimo on it
first red sox with a five-run advantage
two and made a good pitch on him he
struck him out with a slider here's
lindor over one he's grounded out to
third 2-2 to lindor
hot shot
iglesias with a stab out
bro
play that's a dandy roddugo looking to
pick him up hit him a double play in the
first inning sox trying to make it seven
straight wins
there's a drive
heading back pilar on the run he won't
get it takes a hop and there's another
two bases
and jd comes on in to score to make it
seven to one jose glaciers walked and
scored in the second inning and the 2-2
swung and driven to right field
backwards pilar still going back going
hard he reaches up it's over his head
off his glove rolls away a run is scored
and glacier is well on his way to third
here comes the throw and it gets away
goes into the dugout and he will get
home plate two run score how about that
a triple for iglesias and he scores on a
throwing error and the red sox now lead
it nine to one he's in first for jd
davis 2-2 and down he goes hacking 95
miles an hour now a guy who is struck
out a total of 12 times in 19 at bats in
vr
swing and a foul tip to the met back to
back case by chris sale xander at first
bounder up the middle lindor taps the
bag
onto first base and it will turn the
double play another run comes in and the
red sox are beating up on the mets 10-1
as we go to the fifth inning
devers unable to smother that ball
and that'll bring in a run
a hot shot by lindor
endeavors
not able to handle it cleanly that gets
mccann in from third to make it ten to
two that socks with six doubles every
red sox starter has at least one hit
broken battle off the glove
here comes around the score playing
first in time to get iglesias but he
will pick up an rbi
bass goes to third red sox leading in 11
to two mcneal a double a single two for
two as a couple of base runners nobody
out the pitch is swung at it high to
left center field rodulgo moving back
back on the track has the rule makes the
over the shoulder catch out by the
national league scores davis tags and
goes to third hillary treats the first
well the bases are loaded up here for
the new york mets
cranked into center field kk backs up
[Applause]
[Music]
what a throw by [ __ ] dynamite how many
is that for him if he gets this number
eight i believe for him
so here's verdugo he is one for three
with a double
it's softly
charging in on it by us a flip on to get
the out another run in as schwarber will
score second ribby tonight for alex
verdugo headsets lead to 12 degrees kept
the streak alive no one out now pete
alonso pizza for three had a long fly
ball to center that was caught as last
time up
he lines this one out to right field
headed toward the corner and that ball
is out of here
he tucks it into that short right field
corner for his 35th home run of the year
second home run in the series for alonso
and it cuts
the red sox lead to 12-4 they'll send up
the nine man to catch her mccann alar
with a huge lead not being held at first
[Music]
and that is gonna be in there he struck
him out with a slider and that'll bring
up pete alonso
iglesias will dig it and throw them out
runner holding it second
and one away with two men aboard and one
gone
[Music]
little tribbler and off the mat comes
perez out at second and then bobbled on
the transfer that'll score a run so jose
perazza
popped up into right renfro charging in
and that will do it red sox make it
seven consecutive victories
you